[Applaudissements]
merci oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
parce qu'il s'agit d'abord et avant tout
d'une question de cohérence
gouvernementale dont le premier ministre
a normalement la responsabilité madame
sylviane agacinski a été privé par la
présidente de l'université bordeaux
montaigne du droit de s'exprimer
ça ce sont les fêtes les réactions
gouvernementales et surprenante
madame marlène ce qui a pas à sauver
l'honneur du gouvernement en exprimant
publiquement son désaccord qu'il en soit
donné acte madame le ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur directement
concerné puisqu'il s'agissait de
l'université a répondu d'une façon assez
ambigu à notre excellent collègue
charles de la verpillière juristes
éminents qu'un forum serait organisée je
souhaite pour elle que ce forum soit
acceptée par les minorités qui avait
précédemment refusé
madame agacinscki mais vos autres
ministres auraient pu eux aussi
s'exprimer monsieur castaner lorsque des
agents du service public sont privés
d'une formation organisée par la
sorbonne un panthéon formation que
mohamed sifaoui qui est bien connu avait
organisé pour les sensibiliser sur le
terrain de la radicalisation de la même
façon je crois qu'il ya un ministre de
la culture je ne l'ait pas entendu se
désolidariser de ceux qui ont des
programmes et monsieur charb monsieur
charbonnier assassiné avec ses camarades
de charlie hebdo et qui est privé à
titre posthume du droit de s'exprimer
tant à l'université que dans des
théâtres municipaux
nous avons une situation où le ministre
de la culture ou de demain va être
confronté à des journalistes qui n'ont
plus le droit de s'exprimer en direct
c'est le cas d'eric zemmour il y à une
pétition de journalistes et nous avons à
cet instant la certitude que vous ne
respectez vous ne respecter le droit de
parler
que si et seulement si les minorités
turbulente vous en donne l'autorisation